I'm very happy to introduce our next
speaker one of the co-organizers at this
point of the Milwaukee stoic fellowship
as I mentioned as well if you might
you're interested in the walking clocks
it's getting a little cold for them now
but you might be interested in that come
come spring all right yeah I think I'll
still do some yeah this fall I was just
out of town for the last three weeks
very adventurous dan is going to talk
about stoicism and Metta meditation and
we'll go for 20-25 minutes of talk and
then any question and answers are going
to try to keep on track so that we don't
miss lunch the idea so I'm just gonna
turn it over to Dan right now so on
first I want to say my thanks to Greg
and Andy for putting on this stoic on X
as well as our mysterious benefactor
whoever he or she may be so on the topic
of this talk is Metta meditations and
stok Universal love an interdisciplinary
search for Spiritual Exercises on while
studying I like to branch out into other
disciplines that I feel might have merit
and insight to eudaimonia or a good and
fulfilling life that is the project we
are here to find a path that leads to a
fulfilling life a life of tranquillity
and of mind and a sense of purpose
fulfilled and so like I offer up the so
path but I would not deny the thoughts
and ideas of other traditions if they
hold insights into what is useful we are
social creatures and we have desires to
find tools to deal with other people in
a sound and useful way wherever we may
find them
now on some of this would say that I
like Seneca says in his letters to
Lucilius that's you shouldn't be
spreading your learning out too much
he's like stick to the very to the stoic
fundamentals and don't have such a
breath but I feel like that was mostly a
thought that was trying to be pushed
towards someone that was just first
learning the basics of the philosophy
and now with a more grounding of the the
basics of the ideas I feel like I can
you know explore just a little bit so to
follow the stoke path requires both
theory and a lot of praxis or dedicated
action based on the chosen theory the
praxis is needed in order to realize
that equanimity and virtue of the Stoics
our praxis is based on stoic spiritual
exercises spiritual exercises is a term
that was coined by the French
philosopher and master of exegesis
Pierre hadou it is defined as practices
intended to effect a modification and a
transformation in the subjects who
practice them of which premeditative
malorum and the view from above are good
stoic examples and we were talked about
that a little bit with Kevin as well we
can gain some insights into bringing
about these effects in the practitioners
of the spiritual exercises from onder's
Erickson who is well known for his book
peak secrets from the new science of
expertise in his work Erickson puts
forth the idea that extended deliberate
practice to become an expert in any
discipline backed up by a mountains of
data Erickson argues that deliberate
practice defined as motivated learning
with well-defined goals getting feedback
from his performance and as ample
opportunities for a pet repetition is
the basis over the heuristic time period
of about 10,000 hours is the key factor
in developing this excellence stoicism
as a deliberate practice claims to bring
equanimity and eudaimonia
whereas epictetus says it molds and can
strux the soul it orders our lives
guides our conduct shows us what we
should do and what we should leave
undone without it no one can live
fearlessly or in peace of mind or as
Cicero summarizing the early stoke
chrysippus wrote the art concerning with
the cure of therapy or therapy of the
soul is philosophy in other words the
art to cure the mind of the false
beliefs that results in the faulty
judgments that cause unwelcome emotions
here I found the extant Stoke Spiritual
Exercises to be lacking in their ability
to prepare one for some of the tenants
of the theory specifically the idea of
okie osis or stoic Universal love the
idea of okie OSA starts with the idea
that we are born and with concern for
ourselves and our mother and soon to be
joined by our father and this is a
series of interlocking circles wherein
you start out with you and your mom and
dad and then you have your family and
your city
and now you have the universe of
rational creatures and this is on in the
very center here is you and your mom and
dad and this is our most basic level of
concern and then as time goes on we
create new circles of concern our close
family our extended family our
neighborhood and our city our states and
finally the universe of rational
creatures our highest level of concern
is our central circle and there is
diminishing levels of concern every time
that we go up a level of the circle the
act of okie osis is to contract the
circles so that we take the concern of
all rational people and bring them to
the place where you have the same
concern that you would have for yourself
and your direct immediate family on to
become this is the process of becoming a
cosmopolitan a citizen of the world this
is similar to the work of Peter Singer
in his book the expanding circle he
argues that altruism when directed to
one small circle a family tribe or even
a nation is not moral but it becomes so
one applied to the wider circles this
happens because of human capacity for
reason which generalizes or Universal
eise's our altruistic tendencies beyond
groups we are biologically inclined to
be altruistic too as such reason is not
the opposite of emotion and instinct but
instead builds upon it a problem is that
this idea is hard to fathom and even
more difficult to practice unlike many
of the other points of stoke theory the
extent works are of little help here
enter the Buddhists who have an unbroken
tradition over the last you know 2500
years and happen upon some of the same
ideas that the
extending their tradition is more extant
original writings and billions of more
followers over the years they have many
spiritual exercises that can be of use
many of their ex paralyzes focus on
meditation and the many subsets therein
within the Buddhist tradition there's a
practice called Metta meditation or
loving-kindness meditation Metta
meditation is practice by saying sitting
and bringing forth the feeling of
loving-kindness for an individual that
you already have no problem filling love
for and then you try to maintain that
emotional states of love while you start
to think about someone who just you just
might like and not quite love you know
the idea is to mentally associate the
emotional state of love to those who
don't already feel that loving feeling
for it becomes more challenging when you
get to the next level when you then try
to associate that loving-kindness to
those who you feel indifferent towards
and then to feel that same
loving-kindness for those that you may
even hate this is a contracting of the
circle by way of Humes idea that emotion
is the source of morality that we can
use the stoic positive emotion of wish
in order to produce a rational concern
for all rational creatures a wish of
cultivating a cosmopolitan view of the
world now if you're under the impression
that the Stoics deny emotion that we are
these zip off your lips that you know
screw anything that could happen to us
then I would then refers you to the
psychiatrist Aaron Beck and the father
of cognitive behavioral therapy when he
wrote on the subject the notion of
stoicism as a kind of intellectualism
opposed to emotion is a popular
misconception stoicism has traditionally
attempted to accommodate an emotion
expecially the primary philosophical
emotion of rational love towards the
existence as a whole and now this was
just like this idea that Buddhism had
insights into the theories that are
exposed or expounded in stoicism was
just the tip of the iceberg for me the
idea that one can find spiritual
exercises outside of stoicism that bring
forth mental states that describe in the
theory lead to surprising places so
stoic spiritual practices are great but
they are a product of their time most
have to do with self contemplation
looking within and practicing a
situation in which you can react to in a
stoic way in order to have those mental
tools at hand for the real world
encounters practice makes permanent but
some practices are better than other
virtual reality researcher Jeremy
bailenson research lab has literally his
research has led him to the conclusion
that people learn by doing getting
feedback on mistakes and then repeating
and iterating doing is better than
trying to picture the things in your
head that many stok practices are
impossible to do ourselves like the view
from above many other are incredibly
impractical like memento mori or
premeditated malorum this is within the
context of like real world experiences
until now we could not have our own
personal experiences with the ghost of
Christmas future or interaction with
Clarence upon the bridge as Scrooge and
George Bailey were gifted to experience
death and a world without us we could be
we could not experience over and over
the bad things that may befall us on a
daily basis the practice of interacting
with rude persons over and over in our
minds I in order to become dispassionate
to the experience gives us a little
little feedback due to the nature of it
all residing in our mind so enter
professor Jeremy Bell Anson's research
into virtual reality at Stanford
University
and the company spun out of that lab
like this company Stryver there's now
empirical evidence that virtual
experiences can produce significantly
better acquisitions of skills over just
reading about how to do a task or
watching a video of someone doing that
task and trying to emulate it from such
experiences that are difficult or
expensive to experience in the real
world virtual reality is a major boon
Stryver is a company that gives football
cubies and linebackers a 360 video
recreation of plays that they can
practice recognizing what the play looks
like before the ball is even snapped
over at Verizon the tech is used to
Train Verizon employees on how to deal
with armed robbery in order to reduce
physical harm
yeah there's all those things that are
just really difficult to have happen in
any other set of circumstances a train
Ciaran Aereo that would be rather
difficult and expensive to stage in the
real world but with VR the experience
can be run over and over for a very low
cost the training techniques fits in
perfectly with onder's Erickson's
writings on deliberate practice the VR
technology allows for deliberate
practice of usually impractical or
impossible scenarios that bring the
well-defined goals feedback and ample
chances for repetition the VR experience
have also been used as a complement to
cognitive behavioral therapy and
exposure therapy for those who are
suffering from PTSD 35 to 40 percent of
people who do not do not respond to the
standard narrative based on imagery
therapy used in CBT and exposure therapy
jo-ann defeating a specialist in anxiety
disorder Act
Cornell's well medical college pioneer
the use of VR for use in PTSD in
response to the 9/11 attacks the
experience was one where you are
standing at street level and you can
look up and you see the towers and the
ther
this goes through and tries to create an
experience and they can they have at
their fingertips the ability to manually
change the variables of like the time
you know before the first is hit after
the first one hit after the second one
hit and when the towers come down as
well as to add in or take out on other
audio or physical like on like fans and
whatnot to give you some sort of tactile
feedback on in order to try to elicit
that experience in a very visceral way
and to go through the basis of exposure
therapy outside just trying to recreate
that in your own mind the result of the
initial case study was with six sessions
in VR the patient showed an 83 predict
percent reduction in symptoms of
depression and in a 90% reduction in
symptoms of PTSD the therapy was used on
over fifty more people who were
suffering from PTSD from the events of
9/11 with significant statistical and
clinical improvements or the baseline of
mental native narrative exposure therapy
so this brings us back to the stoic
practices that are already several
applications that can be used as a VR
analog to the practice of the view from
above on examples our overview named
after the overview effect and space
engine but the piece de resistance from
my own experience is Google Earth VR and
I just realized that not everyone might
know what the view from above is so the
view from above is a stoic spiritual
exercise that says ok you are in this
place and you think about on an
interaction that you're having in your
so caught up in that one-on-one
interaction that like you're not seeing
the forest for the trees you're not
seeing anything it's all you're all in
your mind and the idea is to take a step
back
and pull yourself up to a hawk's eye
view and be a hundred feet up in the air
and look down at yourself and whatever
you're interacting with at the moment
and say does this thing that I think is
so important actually matter at all at
this moment in time and it's a lot
easier to do that from when you're
imagining yourself at a thousand feet up
or a hundred feet up or a thousand feet
up or several miles up and then you can
extend this to you know the beginning of
time into the end of time and it's like
is is any of this as important as I
think it is at this particular moment in
time
so while Google Earth does not allow for
the zooming out to see the entirety of
our solar system or you in the Milky Way
like the first to do it does allow you
to start from the street where your
house stands as a 3d model and then
slowly zoom out to the point where one
can see the entirety of the earth it's a
really very engrossing experience on
this is part of the idea of the overview
effect which is sometimes referred to as
Earth gazing which is the idea or the
experience that has been described by
many astronauts as they are sitting on
orbiting the Earth and they realize how
small and the the borders that we have
defined for ourselves about our our
world are just illusions and that this
is such a small on and potentially
fragile space that we have to kind of
transcend certain political and on
tribalistic ideas about how we interact
with the world and and so Google Earth
gives you the ability to go basically
anywhere on the earth I've gone to you
know Grand Teton National Park I've
gotten to North Korea I've gone to
Hawaii I've gone to the Great Wall of
China and and you can go down and you
can go to like Street View or just like
hovering a hut a couple feet over the
ground and and then zoom out and then
see the entirety of the earth and you
can have it
and you can see it go from day to night
cycle and it's just this really kind of
centering and calming effect that you
can get from this experience on or you
can also kind of think about it like if
you're familiar with the Hitchhiker's
Guide to the galaxy and there's this
idea of the the total perspective vortex
which takes you and then pulls the back
from to show you the entirety of the
galaxy and the whole idea is to say hey
look how insignificant you are on he
described it as torture but who knows I
think it's kind of fun on he being
Douglas Adams obviously on the idea
going forward is to use these VR tools
in service of stoic goals we can build
scenarios that we once walked away and
ones imagination alone imagine a world
where we can practice premeditated
malorum with the an interactive jerk who
tries his darndest to push your buttons
I am reminded a video of a gentleman who
got into a fender bender
with a very angry US Marine who is
absolutely consumed by that anger the
difference is night and day between the
two men and I will illuminate this with
the said video so if you can see I hope
you can is on I've turned off the audio
because the amount of profanity is
extreme on but as you can see on he is
very very angry and he just wants him to
get out of the car so he can fight him
and if you can see the driver he is
sitting there and making absolutely no
expression and so I feel like this is a
really good example of you know turning
away from that anger that could be there
he's on insulting him his insulting his
girlfriend who is also marine on and and
just using every slur that they can
possibly use to try to and elicit a
reaction from him and nothing happens
and so I've gotta like praise him but
the idea here
is that we could create some sort of
experience where this happens to you you
could sit in that car and you could have
a virtual guy come and just hurl insults
at you to who just you know rattle off
anything that you go to even like choose
like okay what's the one thing that MIT
most makes me on lose my calm composure
and like just dial that up so you're
exposing yourself to like when these
things might happen in real life that
you are already found the dispassionate
ways that you can deal with them so
imagine that you have the ability to
experience that for yourself in first
person to sit in that sea in the car and
watch as he rages and wants to cause you
harm I am convinced based on the
research of Professor bailenson that an
experience like this would be an
effective tool in practicing how to stay
calm in a tense and in provoking events
a virtual premeditated lorem if you will
a library of these experiences can be
built in order to practice a wide range
of cog
negative events to expand the practice
from anger to loss in frustration and
boredom this is all in service to our
main goal of eudaimonia let us seek out
new spiritual practices wherever they
may be found like that that could have
been I could have been really angry
there but you know that just happens
[Laughter]
find new spiritual practices wherever
they may be found and to seek to create
new ones based upon the skills and their
technology at our disposal as a virtual
reality game developer that I am on this
is has become my new pet project I have
the skills in the will to build
something and can help my fellow man I
will need to dig deep in service
my love for all rational beings and put
forth that which needs to be made and on
if you have any ideas of potentially
negative experiences I'm all ears
so thank you all very much
that was my talk yep mhm yeah so your
ammonia is the idea is sometimes
translated as happiness but I like the
translation of on like a fulfilling life
a little bit better because I feel like
kind of conveys the idea better on and
so this is the idea that if you within
stoicism if you practice your virtue on
then that will result in you having a
you die MONUC wife and this is also the
kind of the basis of many of the ancient
schools of philosophy on the resuit
ilion's we're doing this the Epicureans
we're looking for this the Stokes we're
looking for this the cynics were further
looking for this and they all have
slightly different ideas and how you
achieve it and Aristotle said that
virtue is good but also you need like on
some money and some good friends and
some good food and the cynics are like I
all you need is virtue and you should be
an ascetic about everything else
everything else is just on pulls you
away from virtue and the Epicureans are
on
good paying bad on and and if you find a
tranquility within that I'm like a kind
of a a mean within their then you are
living a good life but they also like
remove themselves from society and lived
in their little garden on the souks are
like okay we need to live in society
because we're social creatures and
that's just you know how we are kind of
go to on what Aristotle's a human is a
political animal that we are always in
interaction with other people and and so
the souks said the only thing that is in
itself a good are the virtues but that
doesn't mean that you should on being
ascetic to everything else so you can
have nice things as long as none of the
nice things that you have are ever
traded or is that you never trade any of
your virtues for any of those nice
things um I felt like there was the
second part of that question that I
didn't quite hit on I guess the idea is
that I in order to do virtuous actions
you should on take into account those
people in the the world of all rational
creatures on and the more virtue that
you can do that the more that you bring
yourself towards eudaimonia John you got
a question
I don't know whatever the app kind of
pulls it up oh yeah I've got there's an
app called waking up it's a meditation
app on and and sometimes they do Metta
but most of it is either mindfulness or
zou Chen there's no head yes oh yeah
that's a good one yeah just have someone
just yell at you at very very close
amounts of range yeah okay just let me
add that really quick it's called waking
up and there's a number of different
meditation apps out there I just happen
to have found that that one worked for
me yes yes absolutely you're all here
right on why there's yeah it's been it's
been growing I think we're just at a
point where there's like starting to get
some like mass behind it yeah I don't
anyone else have
and was talking about for many years
they were doing the foundation work yeah
we've been running along sir like
gaining momentum
because it works out there this is part
of you know Kevin can talk about this as
well we're public speakers one reason
blindly to talk about you know
philosophy to ordinary people is because
ordinary people want something that has
soft stem - you could say something soft
them to engagement with ideas that
actually connects with your wife and
that need is not being met by
universities they're doing a terrible
job it's not by the popular culture so
it's being a military and Silicon Valley
and one of the great insights of virtue
ethics in general is we have some
agency over how we feel and we think
rather than just blaming it on somebody
else because well what do I want to work
out so I'm very interested with PR and I
guess I'd also add an you know there's
been populations we're talking about
Ryan holiday he's definitely a
popularizer as well as on Tim Ferriss is
a very large crowd of people that follow
him and he's been a really big proponent
as well so you know whenever people with
big audiences start to push it out there
you know it gets a little bit more
interest and and thanks for like Donald
Robinson and all the other people and
Christopher Guildford actually having
some really good concrete books to work
with yes I don't know until I try on who
knows there's there's going to be some
therapies and experiences that are
probably just not going to work for a
subset of the population on so I would
never say that like it's going to be a
hundred percent but um I think that
there's a good enough parallel research
to say that there is a good chance of
this has on some really useful
applications yes in the back
and I had an experience there were four
major airline and was called out on
Christmas Eve and couldn't be with my
family and I think I was not living
myself to good judgment and resiliency
in etcetera but as we were playing into
Albuquerque the entire city was wrapped
in luminarias with sand on all the
rooftops and I'm just up and down the
streets and as they looked up the window
I don't think it's it's only a Stoke
moment but just yeah that's good it's
great thank you very much for sharing
Bob I'm not super familiar with all of
the points within Zen Buddhism I
definitely see that there's an overlap
and a lot of the ideas on especially
with like having thoughts and your
perceptions about the thoughts thoughts
being one of the major core reasons why
we are upset about things and so I
that's kind of the reason why I was
drawn to at least starting to learn
about Buddhism that there was that
overlap and I guess I found the book why
stoicism is true
Bayan sorry you're right is it what did
I say stoicism okay sorry why Buddhism
is true by Robert right it's a really
interesting look at it from a on a
neuroscience perspective and he he talks
about all the things within Buddhism
that he thinks can be backed up by some
neuroscience research that we have
nowadays yeah John
why nots resource room my impression is
people because go sysm has become a
popular going concern you get people are
like I'm gonna make some money on this
okay so you got some folks there and I
think it's a great untapped market there
hasn't been a good connection between
gap developers and people who really
understand the only one I found though
is even halfway decent was this thing's
called the Stoics and just gives you on
a quote a day from on either you know
the three minute biggies as well as
Rufus and it's just with ads so yeah you
know yeah
on so you're talking about in-group bias
and we've all got it and the idea is to
kind of the opposite of that is to and
we ought to bring in the the amount that
we concern about everyone and when
you're making our decisions to try to
bring that to the same concern that you
would for your innermost in-group bias
it's just kind of an idea of knowing
that we're all part of you know this
community that we work together like the
right hand and the left or the upper and
the lower sets of teeth yeah that that
is the human condition but we can the
idea is that we can use rationality to
try to expand that level of concern to
more and more people
[Applause]
you